make your luck you gotta make your luck
if you keep putting forward to the
maximal effort that luck is gonna come
you're gonna make your luck happen
negative don't sleep in on the weekends
the weekends when you gotta hold the
line instead of worrying about who else
is causing you problems worry about what
you can do to yourself to improve your
station and if you go down that path
you're gonna find you have a lot more
control than you think you do need
motivation watch the top team would
believe nation
he's Jocko willing and here's my take on
his top ten roses success vol 8 and joy
okay let's kick it off with the rule
number one hold the line
people ask me all the time like hey do
you ever take days off and my answer is
I take days off I don't schedule them
but days off happen why because life
happens right sick kid water heater
breaks you know car has a flat tire
can't can't get where I'm supposed to be
boom guess what you just bought yourself
a day a downtime now like travel day if
you got I get some flights that are
whatever they can leave here at 6:15 in
the morning from San Diego and sometimes
I had a late night for me to get up at
3:30 to get a workout in it's actually
counterproductive I'm smoking myself so
then I'll be like okay guess what you
just got a day off it just came
that being said people also ask me what
do you do when you're sick what do you
do when you're tired you know what and
this is a real simple answer do what you
can but you Rudy you just tell me you
didn't have a chance to work out today
you're in the in the room over there
doing push-ups
why do what you can you maintain that
discipline people want to sleep in on
the weekends negative-negative
don't sleep in on the weekends the
weekends when you got to hold the line
the weekends when you got to hold the
line if you sleep in on the weekend till
5:45
well then guess what at night you're all
of a sudden you have a little extra
energy so you stay up a little later so
then Sunday morning you sleep in till
6:30 now Monday rolls around that alarm
goes off at 4:30 and you don't feel like
doing it and you start this downward
spiral right now hey people look don't
get me wrong all right you got to sleep
you got to sleep sleep is very healthy
it's good for you what I am saying you
don't need to get up at 4:30 you don't
need to do that people have different
schedules you got your life going on you
got to figure out what works for you but
I am absolutely saying don't be lazy
I am absolutely saying get on up get on
a regular pattern and maintain that
pattern to the best of your ability rule
number two make better
how do we make good decisions well
number one making correct decisions you
got a study you got to know and
understand you got to know the
background you've got to know the
historical outcomes of equivalent type
decisions that have happened in the past
similar situations and if you know the
history and you know the background then
you can use those to assess the current
situation you're in and then once you
assess the decisions that you can make
assess the possible actions that you can
take and then assess the outcomes that
those decisions will have those actions
will have and when you're doing that you
also have to assess the possibilities of
inaction so a lot of times people forget
that one they don't know they don't know
if they should do a or B what they
forget is there's also what if I don't
do either what's gonna happen sometimes
not doing either is good most that were
a lot of times not doing either is bad
so you got a or B what should you do
maybe sometimes you got a pick air B
sometimes occasionally it's better not
to do anything and you wait and let the
situation develop a little bit more what
so the point of this is whatever you can
know beforehand you know you learn you
study you understand you know the
standard operating procedures you know
what variants variations have been made
on the standard operating procedures and
that's how you go forward and you
execute rule number three be balanced as
a leader you have to be balanced right
you have to be balanced so let's just
take humility and ego because we're
looking for people that are humble but
at the same time you can have someone
that's so humble that they lack
confidence that's bad on the other side
of that spectrum you can have someone
that's so confident that they're
overconfident their egos big and they
don't listen anyone else where do you
want to be you want to be balanced
somewhere in the middle I talked about
the fact that you need to be articulate
as a leader that's great can you be a
leader that talks so much that people
stop listening to you the other end of
the spectrum is you are a leader that
doesn't say enough and now the team
doesn't know what direction they're
supposed to be going in so where do you
want to be you want to be somewhere in
the middle you want to be balanced rule
number four make it like a make your
luck
yeah you're gonna make your luck and if
you will make it if you keep if you keep
putting forth the maximal effort that
luck is gonna come you're gonna make
your luck happen you know that you know
that actually when we when we came went
asking the bruise or came home from Iraq
there was there was you know people like
all you guys got super lucky on that
deployment cuz we got a lot of action
right and there was two like immediate
thoughts behind that was number one like
hey you know first of all we lost our
bros like they're nothing lucky about
that was the first immediate thought in
my head was like hey man like cuz
because the bottom line is SEALs want to
go into combat mad and that's just a
broad statement and so when we came home
had been in a lot of combat and killed a
lot of bad guys and people were kind of
saying hey you guys got lucky and again
the first thought was hey man you know
if this is luck I don't want it
the second thought was just like the
same thing like oh we got lucky we
didn't like cross ourselves and to walk
up and try and be the most you know
prepared we could be and then get
overseas and inform relationships with
all the conventional forces and do good
work for them and continue to you know
just get go as hard as we could the
whole time no that didn't have anything
to do with it was just luck and it kind
of fell into our lap but you know of
course just nod your head and say thanks
man appreciate it yeah good times
so luck is definitely a part of it a
little part because where was i lucky to
be in Ramadi because I could have
deployed a year later and a year later
Ramadi was pacified so is there luck
there there absolutely is so I don't
want to sound arrogant but luck is a
part it's like foot locks it's like a
heel hooks there are a part of the game
you're not a game changer also if you
want to build confidence like jaakko
willing check out my 254 series it's
free and the link is in description
below people want to know how to stop
the laziness and they want to know how
to stop the
rhasta nation rule number five don't
make excuses what is the difference
between an excuse and a reason hmm kind
of a good question right sure
okay and the reason it's a good question
because there's there can be legitimate
reasons why things happen yeah right and
so for instance you're in a in a sailing
race right in a sailboat er and the mast
snaps in half now you don't win the race
yeah but I mean you didn't you know the
mast
snapped mmm what can you do about that
or the weather's the horrible weather
rolls in and you can't launch your
aircraft so you can't go on your mission
well you can't control the weather so
you know like what's up how can that
that's a reason or you get really sick
so you can't compete in a competition
that's a reason you know you were sick
oh you do bad because you were sick and
yet it's a reason could be called you
know now you could look at the situation
and say okay if I'm gonna take ownership
of this did I properly test the mast did
I yeah let me ask you this did we have a
ground-based plan for the operation in
case the weather came in we were gonna
take vehicles instead hmm
right yeah that would work if you get
sick before the competition maybe you
ask yourself were you resting properly
were you eating properly going into the
competition so you wouldn't get sick you
could address that correct yes so you
can still take ownership of things even
if the initial reaction is like oh
others you can't control that well then
you can influence that you could
mitigate it right now can there still be
legitimate reasons yes there can and for
me the the the difference the line
between an excuse and a reason is a
reason you have zero control over right
you've zut you just have zero control
over something happen
well that's a reason guy take it was
almost late the other day for something
no this is borderline this is borderline
huh huh I had an appointment at 10
o'clock I left is a 20-minute drive
mm-hmm I left an hour
I left at well I left about 9:10 I left
50 minutes mm-hmm to drive 20 minutes
but it's just so gonna make it on time
yeah yeah I get on the road basically a
couple roads out of my house and the one
entry way to get on the freeway is
lockdown lockdown hmm like incident like
isolate some incident a guy trying to
kill himself
oh come on a bridge you shut the road
down incident yeah so no one's going on
the highway so what is it everyone's
being channelized into marginal what
they call back side streets yeah really
close rear our yeah the clock is ticking
and and I made it right I made it I was
four minutes I had four minutes to spare
so instead of it taking 20 minutes it
took whatever 46 minutes took more than
twice as long that that could be you
know a fairly legitimate reason now
luckily I had I always you know I had
planned that there could be something
out of my control it might take even
longer and that's why I leave early to
go to an appointment or a situation like
that so I could have also checked the
traffic prior to leaving and taking a
completely different route mmm that
would have been I blame myself so even
in that situation I'm kind of I I was
thinking the whole time what why did you
why didn't I check the traffic before I
left I knew this could have happened
rule number six take ownership what's
the number one thing you look for in a
leader well the first book was called
extreme ownership and what that means is
you're not gonna make any excuses you're
not gonna blame anyone else you're gonna
take ownership of whatever happens and
when something goes wrong instead of
pointing fingers and blaming someone
else you're gonna take ownership of that
problem
you're gonna take ownership of figure
the solution to that problem is and
you're gonna take ownership of
implementing that solution so that is
the number one thing that I'm looking
for for a leader to do is to take
ownership of the problems and again we
call that extreme ownership and it was
one of those things that was very easy
to see in a seal platoon because when
someone doesn't take ownership and
starts pointing fingers and blaming well
like for instance right now if I started
putting my finger and blaming you for
something what's your natural reaction
gonna you get defensive get upset I mean
is I my fault this broadcast isn't what
I wanted it to be exactly exactly and
then what happens is we have a team
where you're pointing that I'm putting
the finger you you're putting the finger
at someone else and now we have no one
taking ownership of the problems and
therefore the problems never get solved
the opposite of that is when you have a
good leader that steps up and says hey
Ben you know what this broadcast didn't
go the way I wanted it to I should have
done a better job preparing - for your
questions I'm sorry I apologize and now
instead of you beating defense if you
say you know what no actually I could
have done a better job and now both of
us are taking ownership of the problems
and we're gonna get them solved if
you're blaming everyone else I can't
control you I can't control these other
things outside I can't I can't control
the only thing I can control is me so
instead of worrying about who else is
causing you problems worry about what
you can do to yourself to improve your
station and if you go down that path
you're gonna find you have a lot more
control than you think you do rule
number seven
yet discipline how many people are like
involved in a start-up right now they're
starting up right cool
so I'll start up is like a little kid
right it's got all this potential it's
got all this potential what happens with
a little kid that never gets disciplined
yeah
little kids that don't get disciplined
turning to Satan that's what happens
and guess what now in the beginning like
a start-up like a baby when you got a
baby you got to do everything for it in
the beginning you got to hold its head
you got to make sure everything's
perfect the way do whatever it takes to
get that thing keep that thing alive you
got to do it but once that thing starts
to expand well then you better start
imposing some discipline on it or else
that thing will turn into Satan rule
number eight focus on the things that
matters as leaders I see people getting
caught up all the times in little things
that will not affect the outcome unless
they let it so I see some white belt
below them in the chain of commands
going all crazy grabbing their sleeve
and this leader on the top like it gets
concerned about it and puts time and
effort into something that doesn't
matter whether it's a little personality
rub a little ego uprising you took
should we do it this way or should we do
it that way it doesn't matter that's a
little sleeve grab it doesn't matter and
I see people getting caught up on things
that don't matter all the time and what
I've realized is it's something that I
figured out a long time ago I don't know
when but a long time ago I figured out
you know what that thing doesn't matter
I'm not gonna worry about it that thing
doesn't matter I'm not gonna worry about
it that thing doesn't matter I'm not
gonna worry about it
that thing matters I'm gonna focus on
that thing mmm and that makes that makes
a big a big big big difference it's its
leadership capital because if I'm
investing my leadership capital and
getting your hand off my sleeve or
trying to do it my way instead of your
way or trying to keep your ego in check
if that's what I'm investing my
leadership capitalist I have nothing
left to vest in the thing that's
actually matters rule number nine
improve your leadership skills do you
think that it really is that leadership
is is blurs it bread yeah I get asked
this question all the time
and so it's both it's absolutely both
and you as a human being are gonna get
certain characteristics that are gonna
make you a good leader and you're gonna
lack some characteristics that would
make you a good leader if you had them
you don't get tens across the board you
know it's like the
little video games you see kids play
where you get a 9 in strength and a and
a 7 in intellect and a and an 8 in
dexterity and you get those 2 as a
leader and you don't get all tense
so some leadership characteristics that
make you a good leader for instance
obviously it's good to be articulate if
you can express your message clearly to
people that's gonna that's gonna help
you from a leadership perspective if you
have some natural charisma that's gonna
help you from a leadership perspective
if you can look at complex problems and
you can simplify them that's gonna be
helpful as a leader because that's what
you're doing so if you're persuasive
there's all kinds of things that will
help you as a leader and you're not
gonna be good at all and so as a leader
if you look at the ones that you're weak
at you can improve them that's that's
what's beneficial so you can't take
someone that's just a horrible leader
and make them into an amazing leader but
you can take someone that's a decent
leader you can make them into a very
good or even an exceptional leader
because how you know you can definitely
get more articulate you can definitely
get more comfortable speaking to people
you can definitely get more more precise
at taking very complex problems and
simplifying them so that your team can
understand what it is that needs to get
done so these are all things that you
can improve upon and I always have to
close this out by saying that there are
some people that cannot become better
leaders and the people that cannot
become better leaders are the people
that can put their ego in check but they
lack humility and those people they
think they're doing everything great so
they're not going to improve as leaders
you can't coach them you can't convince
them they think they're perfect and
they're gonna stay where they are from a
leadership perspective
rule number 10 keep grinding the things
that I'm supposed to be doing aren't
getting done no one's gonna do them for
me and that's the way it's gonna be
right now if I'm laying in bed not only
am i letting myself down I'm letting
down to everybody that's on board
everybody that's in the game and I'm not
gonna let him down it's not happening
you're not able to predict
exactly what's gonna happen so what do
you do you keep grinding don't know why
things happen all always but I do know
this where the opportunities are there
you gotta go now I've got a special
bonus jakka willing cruel on how to
appreciate the light that I really think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go
question number one what are the things
that matter that you need to focus on
number two what excuse have you been
making that you need to let go of and
number three what will you do this week
to keep grinding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you want more Jocko check out the top
50 rules video I made on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there don't wait any more don't
think any more don't plan any more don't
contemplate any more don't make any more
excuses